this is a production of cornell
university
all right well
uh i want to welcome everyone to
hemp 411 we are as always so thrilled to
be here and we're thrilled that y'all
made a little bit of time
to come today it's going to be a really
good one i can promise you that
um so my name is zachary stancil and i
am the usda hemp germplasm curator
um
so i wanted to tell y'all a little bit
about
some of the work we're doing in
beautiful geneva new york which is
snowing again
um today
so we my team and i run a hemp germ
plasma repository so it's basically a
seed bank for genetically and
geographically diverse hemp varieties
so
not unlike a library we maintain this
very unique large collection of hemp
materials
we study them we keep them safe long
term in a minus 20 degree celsius cold
storage area
and we enable scientists to use those
seeds for their various projects for
example breeding a different variety of
hybrid fiber hemp for
a unique environment
or understanding the genetic control of
a certain
trait of interest those are all kinds of
people that would use our resources that
we we keep
um
and then secondly we're trying to help
preserve this genetic diversity long
term so thinking you know in the scale
of hundreds 100 years or more
can we preserve these cool varieties of
hemp for future generations
so it's a big job
it's exciting and
we're really just now starting it
so
um we hope that this work will allow
universities farmers um
hemp businesses all to kind of get a
boost from having access to
unique hemp
um
while doing this work we were thrilled
to meet so many awesome people in
cannabis research and business um
and we
were
[Music]
we thought it would be really fun to
share
um their knowledge with all of y'all
so
i i do want to thank um
george tony our wonderful interpreters
kim and gemma for doing a lot of work
i'm just kind of the
person that talks here
but
absolutely most of all i wanted to thank
alicia ratliff so i'm gonna tell you a
little bit about her and then
let her take over so eliza ratliff is a
fast-moving
consumer goods executive with a
background in chemical sciences
and an interest in carbon sequestration
employed within the cannabis industry
with over 15 years of leadership
experience across several sectors elysia
uses a breadth of technical knowledge
to build startup companies develop
strategic direction
and sustain the brand in new emerging
markets
she is esteemed as a technical
conference speaker author and ambitious
entrepreneur who has become a technical
subject matter expert global thought
leader and motivational speaker she
strives to advise businesses on best
practices
helping them
avoid failing business models and
implementing sustainable policies within
an ever-changing regulatory environment
and alternative market medicines
marketplace so
uh buckle up and
uh here she goes
thank you so much zach uh thank you tony
uh i'd like to thank dr uh grab
in our relationship that we have
for just you know introducing me to such
a wonderful group of people that would
invite me to be a part of something i
think is so important and big so um
hello everyone thank you for taking your
time out today
to spend with me and just learning a
little bit about extraction chemistry
and facility design so i'm going to
share my screen here and
go right into the presentation and
hopefully we'll end up here with a few
minutes for a q a at the end of the
presentation so thank you so much
so uh today we're going to talk about
extraction chemistry and facility design
specifically when i was talking over
you know my part in coming into the
series
we were discussing some of the things
that were of interest of some of the
students over at cornell university and
in the hemp sciences program and one of
those things
that came about was you know learning
how to
build and think about and operate a
successful canvas extraction company
so that is what i'm here to talk to you
guys about this afternoon um hopefully i
can convey some things that
will shed some light to how extraction
chemistry
is deeply intertwined with the facility
design and success of a company
so just to give you a little bit of
background about myself
my background is in chemistry i
graduated from the university of north
florida a few years back
and i have worked in the traditional
laboratory setting for the past few
years
i'm also a licensed project manager i
took on a role later on in my career to
where i came outside of the laboratory
and really started to develop
a lot of the business acumen skills and
just took an interest in understanding
how the scientific aspect of testing um
was you know affecting uh scope of
projects and different things like that
um so i also
took an interest in logistics and supply
chain management i'm professionally
designated in those skill sets as well
i run a consulting firm with my husband
victus consulting ventures
where we are industry consultants and
advisors basically helping new licensees
in new markets really develop their
strategic goals for
building their infrastructure
understanding their product development
and launching those operations in the
new markets
i've also been a scientific executive in
the industry where i've held multiple
roles
gaining experience with startup
companies in the u.s the canadian and
the uk markets
so
again thank you to cornell and the usda
for giving me the opportunity to be a
part of this series um you guys have
heard some amazing um you know webinars
now about cultivation processing systems
and
what i will be talking about i think is
a really great transition from all of
those topics so again we're going to
touch on extraction chemistry and
facility design
but specifically we're going to be
discussing building a canvas
manufacturing site
what goes into that some of the
considerations that you need to think
about um looking at extraction facility
design uh looking at the extraction
chemistry itself some of the mechanisms
and methodologies that are used
in the industry commonly uh then we'll
talk about you know product
development and quality and compliance
and how all of that ties into
your manufacturing plant
then we'll get into some of the products
that can come out of these facilities
and then hopefully end in enough time to
answer a few of your questions
all right so let's jump in
um so when you're building a canvas
manufacturing uh facility you know
there's there's a lot of things that you
need to think about when you go into the
strategic planning phase which should be
the very beginning of the project um so
you know one of the things that you have
to decide early on is you know what is
the level of compliance that i'm seeking
as my standard
one of the things of why i say you know
what is the level that i'm seeking
when the industry got started especially
in newer markets there isn't really a
standardized level
of compliance across the globe for this
emerging industry so a lot of states
will have their own representation in
legislation of what's considered
compliant for your facility so you need
to have a good understanding of what
that is and then
decide for yourself am i going to
essentially just meet state requirements
or will i be the person that's going to
exceed those state requirements in order
to impress and really differentiate my
product in the market um so that's one
of the first things uh one of the second
things is what market am i targeting to
start a business
am i targeting a market that is you know
flooded with vape products is that
something that i want to do um do i want
to just be a cultivator um that is
generating
b2b ingredients of cannabinoids oils and
things like that um there's all these
different ways that you can build a an
intermediary business like a
manufacturing facility um you just have
to figure out what it is you want to do
early on so you can plan those things
out
what type of licensing am i seeking uh
you know this is very important there's
markets in the states that have you know
vertical licensing where you have to own
every single entity that's involved in
producing the product and selling it
from cultivation manufacturing
dispensing
all those different things fall under
your umbrella versus some markets have a
horizontal structure where
you can essentially buy into just being
a processor and you have contracts set
up with farms where you import your
biomass you extract you create product
you white label whatever it is you do
there and then you're able to distribute
that into the market whether that's
through wholesale channels or a consumer
brand um so there's different types of
licenses and so you have to understand
what your license is giving you to
operate in that market um and then some
of the subsets of what you should really
start to think about after those major
points has been
really decided is setting the bar for
your budget really understanding you
know how much money do i need to
fund the startup of this operation how
much money do i need to develop a
product how much money do i need to
sustain operations for x amount of years
before we think about our next fundraise
these are things that you need to take
into account because it'll give you that
operating runway
understanding all of your considerations
that go into building a site
we're going to discuss these in detail
here in a little bit being honest with
yourself and realistic i have
encountered multiple companies that come
into the canvas industry which is dollar
signs in their eyes and understanding
that um this is going to be keys given
to them to unlock revenue in the
billions
but you have to be realistic in what
goes on in this industry as far as the
research and development that goes on in
the product development
optimization of processes the training
of staff
just different regulatory changes that
will affect what you do as a company so
these things you have to take into
account
and finally know the impacts that your
investment are going to have to the
operation and the products overall
so this is a slide that i really love to
show because it just gives an average of
budgets and budgetary concerns and just
having cost considerations at the
beginning of your planning phase um the
assumption that i used here when i built
this
was 2 000 square foot
horizontally licensed manufacturing
facility that operated using co2
extraction technology uh so when you're
building up your budget of the project
and what you're going to need to you
know get this thing um operational then
you have to look at okay i've got to get
a property in building i've got to have
some sort of planning and design
strategy that may involve a team or
hiring you know startup founders
i need equipment to produce this product
i'm going to need software to stay
compliant and show
transparent results of what we're doing
at our facility to the state
i'm going to have you know technicians
or employees i'm going to have operating
costs you know your electrical your
cooling water um so all those things
need to go into the considerations of
what is the cost of you know just the
build out of the infrastructure to be
able to produce um the product
some of the next things that you need to
think about with facility design
considerations are going to be the
building itself
and the materials that go into the
building um am i going to construct this
from you know ground zero or am i going
to
buy a pre-existing building and retrofit
and make sure that it's the appropriate
environments for what i would be doing
in those rooms
those are things that you have to take
into account because they're going to
affect your your budget and your
timeline as well
facility square footage uh this is
something that sometimes people fail to
consider uh future proofing so you may
have a predictable facility square
footage of what you uh foresee or you
may have a pre-existing um you know plot
of land and building that you're using
that you're pretty much you know married
to however i think you should consider
the facility square footage for um
success you know plan to be successful
plan to have expansion plan to
add different revenue streams and
activities to your facility
i think those things are important in
the mindset of just building a
successful business so definitely
consider future proofing your
infrastructure with the facility square
footage
also you need to consider the electrical
requirements from the equipment that
you'll be placing uh the plumbing um the
hvac for uh being able to circulate the
vapors and you know mitigate odors these
things need to be taken into
consideration and you know especially uh
your location of where you're deciding
to build you have to look at the
accessibility as well of these um you
know outputs that are going to be going
into your facility design um so you know
do i have access to the appropriate
electrical that i need to run the
facility do i have access to plumbing um
you know all these different things have
to go into your decision making and
finally your zoning
where can i build this facility and stay
within compliance um usually each state
market has its own um you know spiel on
where you can be located whether that's
a thousand feet outside of school zones
parks where children would be so know
your municipality know where you're
going to be building so that you don't
have to waste time and remediation of a
site
also another consideration in facility
design especially if you're horizontally
licensed as a processor is thinking
about your compliance strategy
knowing that you have a set of standards
set out by the state that you have to
stay compliant to in order to operate
you definitely should think about your
uh testing strategy how am i going to
ensure this compliance and be able to
relate and report this to the state or
to the government agency that's uh
covering me
so you definitely want to think about
that what is your strategy
are you going to be doing in-house
testing or will you have third-party
testing i think it's important to do a
cost analysis sometimes it may be a
little bit more effective to send your
samples out
if you don't have a high traffic of
sending samples to an analytical testing
lab and you can afford the turnaround
times but then in other cases it's best
to have your own in-house
capabilities even if it's as small as
just having an hplc
to be able to have eyes on what is
actually the composition of the product
what are some of the test methods that
are needed in the facility to support
production
you might need to have some sort of
method to test the optimization of what
you're doing
are you efficiently extracting the
material are you wasting um so these are
things that you have to consider and
also consider what that's going to do to
your budget and also to
the people that will be involved in the
project you know have you considered
specific technical laboratory staff so
these are things that also should be
considered going into your facility
design
uh this is extremely important to me you
know growing up in laboratories and
working for traditional laboratories
something that is very near and dear to
me is safety um it's pretty much like
knowing the right hand of
me you have to
regard safety of everyone involved
whether that's the consumer on the back
end or you know the employee that's
producing your product so when you're
talking about your design of your
facility and building this manufacturing
facility you have to
consider your extraction technology and
what you'll be doing to generate the
oils out of the plants
are you going to be using hydrocarbon
extraction if you are then now you have
to build your facility to a c1d1
environment which is a class one
division one uh solvent meaning that
it's highly explosive so there's other
considerations other types of protocols
that have to be put in place
to be able to mitigate against an
incident in where there would be an
explosion
so that's a safety consideration also
ppe what sort of ppe am i going to
mandate in my facility to not only
adhere to compliance of safety of
product but also to keep my employees
safe if they're operating a co2
extractor do they have hearing
protection for the pumps
do they have safety goggles if they're
operating a distillation apparatus so
these things you have to consider
also the environment itself and
sanitizing the environment how are you
going to control the environment
how are you going to handle waste that's
generated you'll have spent biomass that
you have to destroy you'll have
oil that may somehow pick up
contamination that you have to destroy
or remediate how are you going to handle
this waste who are you going to partner
with to destroy it
and also chemical storage since it is a
processing facility
sometimes there's chemicals involved
that could be toxic to the environment
or to people so you have to think about
the storage and also disposal and
management of chemicals as well
and you know something uh that we do
need to touch on now i think that's so
much more prevalent than it was a decade
ago is the conversation around climate
change and really starting to work those
uh details of sustainability and
reversing a carbon impact into uh the
design of the facility some of the data
that has come out from mature markets in
california and colorado have shown
that manufacturing facilities and
extraction plants have a very high
energy demand
they can have a high carbon emission
rate or a large carbon footprint and
also generate large amounts of waste so
i think it's important that we think
about some of the things that we can
implement
into future facilities to be able to
mitigate some of these factors and drive
a net zero strategy for the business
so kind of uh pivoting here and just
kind of
understanding chemistry and cannabinoid
extraction chemistry i like to kind of
take it back to the historical uh terms
and you know what things were back in
the ancient times so what is botanical
extraction botanical extraction is
placing a solid
in a solvent in order to remove soluble
dissolvable components um so we've seen
this you know across the industry in
multiple methods and techniques and
pieces of equipment which we'll talk
about here in later slides
plants they've been found historically
over centuries to provide therapeutic
properties
so a lot of why botanicals have started
to be become extracts was to dissolve
these plants in solutions to concentrate
those properties in the compounds that
we were extracting out
to separate those medicinal analytes
from the plant matrix and really develop
you know further drugs so i think it's
quite interesting that the natural
extracts have been used as active
ingredients in both you know
pharmaceutical applications but also
cosmetics and wellness products for
thousands of years before we've even you
know come to the point where at now
so some of the things that you have to
think about when you talk about a
manufacturing facility and extraction
facility
is the extraction chemistry itself uh
the process of separating a substance
from a matrix is the definition of
extraction
there are several types of extraction
mechanisms that are that can be used to
facilitate this process
you have liquid liquid extraction
solid phase extraction acid-base
extraction and also supercritical fluid
extraction
specifically two of these mechanisms are
very common in this industry and we'll
discuss those here
in a little bit
so here's some of the common
methodologies that are used in the
cannabis and hemp industry
you have the hydrocarbon extraction
which is using a butane or a propane as
a solvent
this is extremely popular it was first
regarded as extremely unsafe and very
dangerous due to its popularity in the
west coast very early on when the
industry was growing however you know
we've become very sophisticated the
manufacturers of closed-loop systems
have become very sophisticated in how
butane is stored handled and
used without within the extraction
process
that has made it a lot more safe
it has its advantages in the industry as
being a solvent that is
highly selective in bringing out um you
know the terpenes is able to retain
terpenes it's um kind of like a low and
slow extraction so um it's it excuse me
it's a low extraction as far as you know
boiling points and things like that so
you're able to increase your um run
times and you're able to increase your
yields so this definitely has its place
in the industry and i like seeing the
innovation and automation that's been
coming about with the equipment
supercritical co2
this is not new
technology it's been used for many years
with distillation and removing
ingredients from botanicals
but supercritical co2 is very good at
selectivity and also it's a natural
solvent so
when it's being purged it's essentially
like effervescing into the atmosphere
safely so um it has its advantages with
the safety
aspect and the component of purgability
out of the product
definitely a high capex cost and
equipment but with a lot more
manufacturers starting to come online
it's starting to drive that cost down to
a more reasonable state
and you do have ethanol extraction as
well ethanol extraction is interesting
because as a solvent it has the ability
to be both polar and non-polar so it can
extract essentially anything from the
plant it does have its disadvantages in
that you have quite a bit of
post-processing on the back end of the
oils
from just different
less desirable components and compounds
that you don't want in your final
product
but it definitely has its place in being
able to
extract very large amounts of hemp
and cannabis at very fast rates
and then you have ice water extractions
this is commonly known as your
solvent-less extractions in the industry
although from a chemical standpoint it
would be
just less appropriate for me to have
referred to
ice water extractions as solvent list
because water is a solvent
however these are becoming much more
popular as well because of the um
inherent dangers and risks of you know
um residual solvents in uh products so
the consumers have started to show an
interest in the craft um product
production of um you know concentrates
through using an ice water extraction um
and pressing so that is becoming a lot
more popular and it's also becoming
popular in the fact that it drives the
cost of construction down because
there's no specific environment that you
have to work within as far as safety
regulations go
and it's also very inexpensive to outfit
the kit is very inexpensive compared to
some of the cost of like your super
critical co2 fluid equipment so
this is definitely something that's
gaining a lot of
popularity in the industry
so just kind of coming out of the
extraction piece
that's just the beginning of the
manufacturing plant now you have to
think of how am i going to develop and
produce all of the products in my
portfolio am i producing vape cartridges
tincture oils edibles whatever that
looks like you have a process so i like
to show this process flow because this
is going to affect
your budget with ancillary equipment
and subsequent manufacturing equipment
software
just all sorts of different things so
you have to think of the process of
having the biomass and the contract set
up in place
having your extraction technology
how are you going to winterize what is
your strategy for winterization
how are you going to filter and de-wax
if you're using ethanol extraction
decarboxylation to activate the thc in
your cannabis products and then finally
how are you further concentrating or
isolating products if you're
an ingredient manufacturer so
these are things that you have to be
cognizant of when you're thinking about
your sellable product to the market
so talking about the products now being
produced in your manufacturing facility
there's a quality threshold in a product
specification that's put out
through the state market that you're
operating in or whatever country you're
operating in um so there's regulatory
compliance considerations that are now
starting to bring their way into the
design of the facility uh what is your
testing program are you going to have
that internal testing program where you
have in-house capabilities
that are just confirmed and checked by a
third party or will you be doing
everything externally through a third
party um partner
that's something that you have to
consider because it will affect your
budget and your personnel
also gdp making sure that you
communicate and put in place good
documentation practices all across the
organization this is the only way that
you'll be able to really check the pulse
of how the business is doing once you're
operating and able to um find those
areas that you can improve optimize and
really shave down waste uh generation
your equipment materials this plays a
role in being able to satisfy a food
safety or gmp sort of standard depending
on what market you're in um so you
definitely want to look at the equipment
materials that are in contact with your
product um again going back to
environmental controls and sanitation
how am i sanitizing the environment
between batches between
days and crews
you need to make sure that you have
those things in place as well and
optimizing your processes how are you
going to do that are you going to scale
up and have
more pieces of equipment and expand are
you going to automate processes these
are things that will also future proof
your business for
plans of expansion
so why is testing needed in the canvas
industry well one of the reasons why
testing's needed in the industry is
first and foremost to test the chemical
makeup of the material of the product
this is something that hplc has been
really great at achieving with um you
know cannabinoid potency methods being
developed from multiple manufacturers as
well as
product manufacturers so
you definitely want to have testing
that's involved
at your facility so that you can just
test your products and see what's in it
and where you're at
also the presence and detection of
contamination is important um just from
a compliance standpoint safety
standpoint you don't want to sell
product that you unwillingly know is
laden with microbials um so you
definitely need to have a testing
strategy in place to be able to um
confirm and mitigate any presence and
detection of contamination uh regulatory
compliance usually every uh market will
have some sort of standard for testing
whether that's holding you to a standard
internally or externally so you have to
make sure you incorporate testing to
have the regulatory compliance box
checked
and also product and consumer safety as
we talked about making sure that you're
being completely transparent with what
you're selling to your consumer and
having that door open to where they can
double check and look through
data and metrics to say okay this does
confirm what the packaging or the label
has claimed
so just to give you an idea of what a
consumer would see
here's a summarized coa this is
basically giving the potency what the
percentage of thc is in the product
who prepared it what the terpene profile
is and the containment analysis shows
whether or not it's passing or failing
for heavy metals pesticides mycotoxins
and microbials
these tests have become standard in the
industry you'll usually see these across
a coa you don't necessarily have to
have a full panel in your testing
package but this is usually typical of a
final product before it's sold in a
dispensary
you also have detailed coas and these
are my personal favorite because you
know i like to get a little nerdy with
the numbers
and just really enjoy seeing if there's
any trends in data that i can kind of
monitor to see if there's anything you
need to put in place early on for any
contaminant spikes so a detailed coa is
going to give you things like an image
of the product that's being tested
in this example they're testing flowers
so you have a picture of the flower
there you have
safety check which concludes
certain analyses then you have your
cannabinoid content grafts you have
specific concentrations and how those
work up against the method lods so this
is a very detailed coa um this is
something that essentially a consumer
this might be overwhelming to them
but for a product manufacturer this is a
very informative
for process and for what's being
performed
so the necessity of the compliance piece
is uh extremely important and it's it's
connected
it's interconnected with the facility
design and how you're going to run the
business
a lot of how your business model is
going to be drafted and planned is
essentially given to you through the
standards of the state market that
you're working within or the regulatory
agency of your country um so there's a
there's no guesswork there which is nice
but you do have to put in your own
pieces to make sure that you're um you
know granting consumer and employees
safety at a high priority um that you're
following all of your licensing
requirements to keep uh your co and make
sure that you stay operational
you're in continuous production and you
don't have pitfalls and equipment
breakdowns frequently because you've
already planned for those risk factors
and you have a very safe and sanitized
environment that you're controlling your
product within so compliance is
extremely necessary to the success of
starting up and operating a
manufacturing business
also compliance is important because
you're building trust with others you're
also avoiding criminal charges because
you're staying compliant within your
licensing requirements you're avoiding
fees penalties being shut down having
products recalled these things can be
detrimental to a startup company
you're improving your public relations
by being transparent with your product
and providing consumers with the
information that they need to make an
informed decision between brands um
you're also attracting and keeping the
right talent to produce the product for
you because you're also transparent to
your staff
and making sure they understand your
priorities in quality and safety
you're also reducing any unforced errors
so you don't want to have the redundancy
of having to go back and remediate and
fix
every five seconds you run into a
challenge
so now that we've kind of discussed a
facility design a bit of extraction
chemistry and technology um how that all
kind of flows into manufacturing a
product to uh you know sell into the
market um you know this leads into
operating a successful canvas
manufacturing business all of these
different pillars that we discussed uh
so let's look at the products that can
unlock the doors of revenue uh for your
newly formed company that you now
understand exactly how
to operate compliantly legally and
hopefully profitably
so i know that we're talking about a
cannabis manufacturing plant which
usually is a middleman
to cultivators and the dispensaries
however i just really love paying homage
to the flower the flower is where it all
begins this is where a lot of the
cannabinoids and therapeutic benefits um
you know belong and they this is why
we've all jumped into the industry so i
love showing the product of flower
because this is the um
this is the input into all of the
infused cannabis products that hopefully
you'll be making out of your facility
here's some of the most common
infused cannabis products in the market
um i would say a lot of these common
infused canvas products now that i've
worked
in several markets globally
this is definitely on the north american
side the north american market is very
mature as as to where cannabis products
are now becoming um a lot more
commoditized you're um having a lot more
companies that are going public so it's
just a different environment compared to
like the uk europe who are now starting
up and just really starting to
navigate how they want to build the
regulatory environments
so these infused products go really
beyond this list but some of the common
ones that you'll see are like tincture
oils the tincture oils are very common
in epileptic patients
in children tincture oils are really
good for people who really crave that
discretion in consuming cannabis
products
vape cartridges these are becoming
extremely common and popular
even though that we had the issue of the
vape crisis with you know some really
illicit things being used as filling
agents and vape carts i think it was a
wake-up call to several industries to
just really understand uh the product
quality piece and the consumer safety
piece so
you're starting to see a lot of
innovation in the formulas for the vape
cartridges which is exciting
in medical markets and some adults you
have capsules being produced alongside
edibles the edibles are really you're
starting to see a big jump in um edibles
across markets in their innovation and
the changes you have you used to have
just gummies and chocolates but now
you're starting to see gummies
chocolates um granolas fruit bars
there's just all sorts of things so um
that's pretty cool um and then
concentrates uh concentrates are for in
my opinion the more sophisticated canvas
connoisseur um that needs something
that's gonna be a little bit more potent
typically your concentrate products are
going to be higher than 70 percent
of your active ingredient whether that's
cbd concentrate or thc concentrate um so
these are interesting but these are
actually starting to gain a lot of
traction in the market with popularity
as well because of the
artisanal production of a lot of the
concentrates and um being able to do
that with a lot of solvent list methods
so it makes them extremely safe as well
um and a lot of consumers have said
concentrates are the uh closest picture
to the cannabinoid profile of the
original flower biomass so that's
extremely important to um just kind of
note
and just kind of digging in with the
concentrate product variety there's you
know obviously rosin resin shatters
waxes butters crumbles
these things are evolving in the
industry as well
and i really love talking about some of
the novel products too
the innovation of this industry and
having a lot of people involved from
multi-disciplinary backgrounds is really
starting to show in the research and
development of product formulations and
the applications of products so now
you're starting to see novel products
pop up in the wellness industry through
the form of topicals
you have infused shampoos and
conditioners
you have all sorts of things now in the
wellness industry you have
sexual health products that are now
starting to be developed in an infused
manner you have beverages transdermal
patches sublingual sprays i read a study
um the other day about
eye drops being developed to help with
glaucoma patients
and then cosmetics so there are so many
different
things that are being developed in this
industry and the fun thing about product
development if you're you know really
focused on developing a cannabis
manufacturing or extraction facility
then you have um the ultimate
opportunity to be able to really
penetrate the market with something
that's a little bit more niche or
something that's differentiated you know
oldie but goody but that's the cool
thing about understanding the extraction
chemistry and product development
alongside operating a compliant facility
so thank you
very very much everyone for uh joining
me this afternoon for a quick blurb
about
extraction chemistry facility design
product development and what can come
out of that facility and i just really
hope you were able to take away a few
things um if as you can see my contact
information is listed here on this last
slide um you can reach me by email
website we're on instagram linkedin as
well but thank you very much for um your
attention and i'm going to turn it over
to open it up for questions
awesome thank you so much
exactly
no just that was mind-blowing thank you
alicia oh thank you so much
um i'll just remind all of our
participants if you have any questions
please put them in the q a box you can
find that at the center of the bottom of
your screen and then i'll work through
as many as i can in the next uh 15 or 20
minutes here
alrighty uh so our first question um
could you elaborate on what hplc is and
maybe how it's used to the industry sure
so hplc is considered high pressure
liquid chromatography
you also have uh plcs which are ultra
high pressure liquid chromatography
that's just a mechanism for separation
so
hplc is an instrument that's used in the
analytical laboratories to essentially
separate your um cannabinoid content
from the product matrix and give you a
an accurate quantitation based on
standards so it's a piece of equipment
that is extremely common across the
industry in order to test for
potency and product composition
awesome
our next question is about
what people can do with spent
uh hemp biomass presumably after it's
extracted
sure
that's a really good question and
honestly that depends on where you are
some markets will allow you to
essentially have your own waste
management plan and you submit that and
as long as you're adhering to that it's
fine but there's also other markets that
will dictate you have to
incinerate or you have to compost it or
you know just anything like that so um
it just really depends but um i would
say some of the common ways of just
disposal of spent material has been like
i said um you know having a contract
with a disposal company that gets rid of
it for you
having some sort of incineration
technique
or being able to
reuse that
in your crop cultivation
awesome
um we have another question about
um
are there are there different kind of
testing requirements for hemp
versus thc cannabis in
different states
and
i guess do you think that hemp should be
regulated or tested as heavily as as
high thc cannabis
oh that's a good question so um from a
scientific standpoint there is no
difference between the analytical
methodology that's used for the potency
for the cannabinoid profile of hemp and
the cannabinoid profile of cannabis
it's the same exact method that you run
to be able to tell you what that potency
is
so there is no difference there i would
say the only difference that of what
you're looking for though has to do with
the legislation and the regulations so
um with the hemp industry if you're
working in a hint market then you're
subjected to biomass that's no higher
than 0.3 percent
that's in the states though by the way
because i have worked in multiple
markets so like in the uk it's point two
percent um it's just different across uh
places in europe so just knowing what
your threshold is if you're in a hemp
industry um and then you can put into
place how to um harvest properly or
cultivate towards those limits but there
really is no difference and then as far
as
the testing regime
one i'm going to always be on the side
of rigorous testing because it's going
to keep the consumer safe
for me as a producer if there's an audit
every week of someone coming in and just
essentially checking the temperature of
my facility as a consumer of my product
i want that i want to know that you're
going through all these random
inspections to make sure you're keeping
me safe um so i definitely think that we
have to have rigorous testing in the
industry um but i don't think that we're
to the point um just
educationally that we understand what it
is we're testing for um and what's
considered legal and illegal i think
they're the lines are very blurred there
at this moment in in our um political
landscape and i think until we define um
you know what's being considered illegal
and legal whether it's cannabis as the
plant or whether that's actual thc cbd
then it's going to be very hard to be
able to tell in the future
how the testing strategy of whatever
market or government you're operating in
is going to look like
awesome
uh can you make a comparison of
different extraction methods with
regards to which is the healthiest to
consume
oh sure so um there's a lot of studies
out there show um you know one the
purgability of solvents um from cannabis
products and related matrices um it also
shows you know just how that
removability affects the product so
um if you i'm sorry can you just repeat
that one more time i start to answer
these things and have a train of thought
yeah different methods and and which
ones might be healthier or less healthy
right right right
so um that all depends again on the the
purchability of the solvent so um a lot
of consumers have said and i'm going to
say this from a consumer standpoint of
research but a lot of consumers really
enjoy co2 extracts
because of the natural effervescence of
co2 from a product it will naturally
purge itself
and it's also not
considered toxic
and then you know when it comes to other
products as far as consumption as long
as they're within the specifications
that are laid out
within your regulatory market is being
considered safe um there are quite a few
solvents that are um they're they're
called gross solvents g-r-a-s which are
generally recognized as safe solvents so
as long as you have them below exposure
limits below those permissible limits to
toxic exposure then you should be okay
with any product
of how it's being extracted as long as
that's being purged properly
great
um another question uh to what extent
are you finding individual growers or
farms building on-site extraction or
processing facilities
um well it depends you know there's it
depends on budget and then it depends on
experience you know there are some
people who have the budget and they've
experienced having um challenges with
biomass being contaminated when they
receive it um having to remediate those
things within their facility before they
can sell a product and then obviously
that taps into profits so those um cons
those scenarios um i would say that at a
rapid pace those people are um
considering cultivation licenses so they
can start um vertically integrating to
control their supply chain as much as
possible um but then on the flip side
you you would say there's people that
just aren't attracted to that model
because um of the ongoing implications
of having now a secondary business
that's attached to your primary business
it has its own risk its own
operation and overhead costs and things
like that so
it really just depends on your scenario
and what you're doing
but there's definitely just a it's not a
one size fits all industry which is kind
of nice so you do see uh quite a few
scenarios playing out in multiple
markets
awesome
another question
what are the best home testing products
on the market at present
oh that's a great question and honestly
i wish i could answer it thoroughly
however i have not delved into the home
testing products um in my opinion i'm
just such a skeptic of you know the
quick um you know scan and you'll give
me 50 thc in my product type products
but i just don't have enough knowledge
um around the subject to just give an
informed answer but i definitely think
if it's using robust technology if you
can you know do your due diligence on
the equipment to you know just confirm
that it does what it does and there's
some accuracy there then i would say
that's a development that has a lot of
traction um for the future
awesome
um there's a couple questions about the
difference between uh delta 8 and delta
9
thc you could touch on that
uh sure so the difference between delta
a and delta 9
is a
little bit of the psychoactivity
and how it binds to the receptors in the
endocannabinoid system and how long that
binding
lasts so what the effects are so i would
say those are the biggest differences
between deltae and delta 9.
again it depends on your individual
cannabinoid system to say which one is
more psychoactive versus the other
some people have reported that they
don't feel a difference it feels like
cbd to them um some people have said
that it's more psychoactive than delta
nine but that's all obviously dependent
upon your own unique cannabinoid system
um but for the most part uh just you
know structurally uh the differences are
the psychoactivity levels how it binds
and how long those um bindings um
interact
great
another question
um
what innovations do you see um
coming for cannabis extracts also what
would you personally like to see in the
market that you haven't seen just yet
oh so some of the innovations that i see
coming in the market have been around
automation honestly um you know a lot of
the demand of the market and a lot of
these markets opening up globally
it's really starting to show that uh
startup companies in the beginning may
have thought that their market size was
a certain way but now they're starting
to see that that demand is high so i
just i think there's such a an
opportunity for innovation um just on
the scale-up piece of being able to
produce at higher volumes and still keep
that
craft quality that a lot of
sophisticated canvas connoisseurs love
and i definitely think there's some
innovation around product formulations
as well
something that i would really love to
see would be a lot more products
formulated around women's health
there's definitely a lot more
conversations that are being had around
women's health and pain
pain with menstruation uh different
things with sexual health so it'll be
nice to see research going in that
direction and really starting to um
revolutionize that type of medicine
another question
with regard to sustainability and
specifically energy consumption have you
encountered any extraction facilities
that are already running off of 100
clean or renewable energy
how realistic is it to achieve this
level of sustainability considering the
typical energy demands of these
facilities
sure so uh no i have not encountered a
facility just yet that is just a hundred
percent sustainable and uh renewable
energy
however i definitely think that that's
something that is achievable but i think
it's going to take some time and it's
going to take multiple partners
collaborating around the world
it's going to take the partners that
obviously have the funding to be able to
you know
put those infrastructures in place for
their facility but it's also going to
take um the development and the data and
actually testing those methods to see if
it's working and how it's affecting
yields of crops and things like that so
i don't think we're quite there yet in
the conversation to be able to produce
real world data but i definitely think
there are firms across the world that
are working towards that goal
awesome
um another question kind of on that line
when it comes to product design do you
feel like more products should or could
be designed to minimize their waste
that's a really really great question
and yes i do so kind of coming back to
vape carts just to bring that example
you know you're when you're using a
filler or cutting agent you're
introducing um an another ingredient
into the formula so um by cutting out
the any type of cutting agents that are
coming into the formula and just using
cannabis oil terpenes and just different
you know mixes of those
i think right there you cut out waste
and you're able to operate your line a
little bit more lean
you've just cut out an ingredient you've
cut out
any type of issues with packaging um as
far as that ingredient goes and having
to store it so there's just a lot of
ways that you can kind of think about
innovating on a um a lean way and
optimizing those processes from that
standpoint
we have a question about
co2 dissipating from products after
extraction and whether
people have looked at whether
it dissipates or
it
degrades into oxygen and carbon monoxide
that's quite interesting um i have not
uh heard about that study or research
but um definitely would be looking into
that um from what i understand i haven't
seen you know i've been in the industry
for six years and i haven't really seen
anything come about um as far as co2
extracts having any undesirables and on
the back end um but yeah i'd be
interested in any type of study that's
uh showing any sort of risk factors
um can solvents degrade over time
and or reduce the amount of cannabinoids
extracted from the plants
yes absolutely so
one of the things i can say about that
as far as an example when you're using
ethanol
for instance so ethanol obviously has a
proofing
and you can have you know 200 proof
ethanol and that 200 proof ethanol can
lose its proofing over time especially
if it's open container to the
environment if it's collecting any
moisture then it's going to start to
degrade so you definitely have to keep
an eye on that
test your solvents regularly to just
keep that into compliance
and also too if you're recycling solvent
so if you're recycling co2 in a closed
loop system or
even ethanol extraction you have to look
at how many times you're saturating that
solvent upon recycling of use
so that will also start to degrade the
solvent and
reduce the tunability of what it can
select and actually extract out
can you talk about what distinguishes a
botanical extract from a botanical
infusion
there are different licenses yes so it's
that's a great question so a botanical
extract remember we're using a solvent
to essentially pull the analytes out of
the plant matrix so a botanical extract
is essentially taking um you know the
buds and passing it through the co2 and
then now you have your cannabinoids in
there um an infusion is taking the
cannabis the cannabis oils or the
cannabinoids and actually infusing those
into a matrix so um i would say they're
kind of opposite mechanisms you have
infusion which is bringing it into a
matrix and then you have your botanical
extraction which is taking them out of a
matrix
another question on uh spend
hem biomass what is being discussed in
terms of use for food and or animal food
also that's interesting there's a little
bit of research being done in the states
there's also research being done over in
europe
regarding animal feed and being able to
pelletize him
spent him biomass
for a lot of the researchers what
they're looking at is going to be
one the solvent that was used because
they have to check that it's under a
certain permissible level obviously for
an ingestion of the animals um so that's
going to take some time
and then you know obviously the
stability
and making sure that those proteins stay
active for the animals so i know there
are studies around the animal feed piece
there's definitely studies being done
also
around animal bedding because hemp has
shown to be a great odor mitigator
it's highly absorbent without the odors
similar to hay but just a little bit
more effective so there's studies around
that as well um i think probably in the
next couple years we'll start to see
some
provisional licenses or research
companies coming out with different
innovative ways of applying it what
considerations would you suggest with
regards to gmp standards for facility
design
so again i'm a lab rat so i'm always
going to say high quality
high consideration to safety so when it
comes to gmp standards i definitely
think that um if you can afford to
outfit your facility to meet the highest
standards whether that's you know if
you're in the states 210 to 11
if you're in you know europe it's eugmp
but um if you can meet the highest level
of standard i think you should go for
that every time because again um just
kind of taking off the hat of
entrepreneur capitalist you have to
think uh this is a product that i'm
putting into the market for potentially
children to consume or you know
immunocompromise elderly people to
consume so you do have to have a bit of
a conscience there
could you talk about baseline cost
approximations uh comparing different
extraction methods uh kind of generally
what would be more or less expensive in
regards to equipment
sure
um so i i've done a presentation before
uh speaking about extraction um
equipment and what the pricing has been
and i can say just historically uh when
you're looking at high capex costs
usually your supercritical fluid co2 is
going to be at the top of the list um
one of the reasons is behind you know
the pumps that are needed uh the
condensers that are needed to recycle
the solvent you have just the pure scale
of a lot of the co2 instruments and the
pressure uh ratings that you're using
when you're in service so the the safety
implications there's a lot there
that you have to consider so that's
usually the highest cost
on the lower end is usually the ethanol
equipment the ethanol equipment's
usually the lower end of the scale
and we're talking
i've seen pieces of equipment as cheap
as you know 75 000 up to maybe like 135
for an extractor and then those are
easily scalable
and then with co2 equipment you're
talking anywhere from 125 to half a
million dollars
depending on the capacity of your
extraction vessel
and then hydrocarbon extractors i would
say fall towards the lower end of the
capex budget um and they
and i do think it's because of their
not so high desirability when it comes
to the safety piece
but also
because it's highly scalable too
similar to the ethanol equipment so um
and then solventless equipment is
obviously at the very lowest end of the
run because you're talking about maybe a
five gallon bucket and you're throwing a
bunch of bud inside with a shovel and
you're mixing it around no i'm just
kidding that was five years ago but now
we're talking about just these like wash
vessels with uh you know paddle mixers
um a rosin press so it's not anything
that's sophisticated technologically so
it's gonna be a bit cheaper
so we're coming up on the end of the
hour do we have time for one more or
should we just
give her a huge round of
applause for her that's the questions
that put her through the ringer already
congratulations to our guests for coming
up with a lot of awesome questions and
ideas
as well oh thank you
i really appreciate it i had so much fun
this was extremely interactive and i
just really hope
someone in the audience was able to take
something away i think uh our purpose in
this part of the industry with all of
these um opportunities is each one teach
one and if we can lift someone else up
and just push them in a forward
direction then we're doing our jobs
wow
awesome hey thank you all all so much
for coming here today and see you in two
weeks
thank you bye everyone
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu